yeah nobody's ever done three podcasts
with us well rock and roll we have a lot
to talk about because I basically was
pronounced dead on Elvis's birthday
December 8th did not know that I had
like gnarly covered my body was shutting
down and uh I went into four seizures
and each one lasting 10 to 20 minutes
and on the fourth one I bit my tongue so
hard it was like nearly falling off it
got so swollen and puffy it wouldn't fit
in my mouth and I was drinking the
infected blood which gave me pneumonia
as well
so when Naveed the shaman took me to the
hospital I went in my fifth Caesar and I
couldn't breathe without a tube down my
throat so I woke up five days later
thinking I was there for a couple hours
like dude you've been here for nearly a
week we tried to take the tube out and
you weren't breathing on your own so we
had to put it so I I spent eight days in
there and um dude when they took that
tube out I felt like I sucked on Darth
Vader's dick I had to sip one tea and
[ __ ] Los Angeles it was all to live
long day you don't remember anything
while you're out no you were your heart
was stopped yeah you have a near-death
experience
no I just kind of I just blacked out I
didn't have any like out of body
experience I have before but not on that
one wow yeah now
this this was not
uh a secret this was on TMZ yeah like
like as soon as it happened yeah and I
can tell you that for me
seeing bam
bams on uh [ __ ] ventilator meaning
you can't breathe by yourself you're in
I didn't say that beep that
you're in the ICU yeah Intensive Care
Unit in critical but stable condition
I'm just thinking oh my God like this is
it like uh like and the the
what's terrible is that my my first
legitimate thought was
[ __ ] bam better not die dude it's
gonna ruin my tour it's gonna ruin
everything
yeah people didn't like that on the
comments yeah they were like Steve was
thinking about this tour
what a selfish prick
but he's saying it to Bama's face and
Bam would probably be like yeah I mean I
would say the same thing
so you guys really look at the comments
oh dude I well just on the Zach one
because I read the first Zach podcast
and I was like Jesus dude these people
are going hard and then everyone was
going so that was one of the things on
the Zach one right okay well I said it
to be him and I'm kind of being fun and
for sure you know there's an element of
truth to it but like whatever the most
important thing is that Bam's not dead
yes and uh Jesus that's important I used
to be in the end it's slightly important
I used to be an EMT in the in in one of
the stats that they gave us was when
somebody has a seizure
every one minute of seizing you lose the
same amount of oxygen oxygenated blood
as running a marathon oh yeah so like
when somebody has a seizure for like a
minute and then they're like doing the
Thousand yards there afterwards like
because they're dead [ __ ] exhausted
yeah man I just like drink molasses to
coat my throat I sounded like you for
like a good day
how did you get the voices sound like
you sucked on Darth Vader's dick was it
swallowing that [ __ ] goldfish I don't
know or maybe all those uh other Senior
Week parties that you got paid for back
in the day everybody
talking and your thing was bashing beer
over your head and then drinking it
rocking the Slayer dude the the it turns
out hitting yourself in the head is not
good for you
welcome yourself to every town in
England and then getting choked out and
passed out until you got knocked out
yeah what was on tour that was when I
was on tour with Don welcome to Brighton
England
welcome to Bristol
do you remember
were you choked out by Jean LaBelle yes
maybe yeah we all were that was intense
they said it was too dark to put on TV
because like but basically like died and
then came back and then you're just like
whoa what just happened they're like
this is too dark to put on TV right or
even in the middle and what Gina Belle
does it real quick that's a deal fast he
gets you unconscious so fast
um and and yeah they didn't want to use
the footage but having had the
experience Ryan Dunn felt totally
qualified to just go around choking
people unconscious of yourself yeah it
made me so uncomfortable we were on tour
and he would be like to the audience who
wants to come on stage and get choked
out and and I'd be like no dude done
don't do this this is awful this is
awful don't do it here just do it and do
it and then one day I was just awake for
enough days in a row on drugs I was like
okay dude I want this footage done
that took me out again again six times
in one day wow when you were in your
drug Heyday didn't you have like three
to four Apartments down on Martel in
Hollywood one was a complete skate park
one was filled with vodka and
grapefruits and then the other one was
like a [ __ ] pad
good Budweiser
yeah I saw footage of you there one time
when you were trying to sleep but you do
you remember that yeah yeah yeah and
you're like nah just let me go to bed
and like they're pulling your pants down
yeah yeah where we stripped you Nick I
don't know if we ever did anything with
that footage man we've got a lot of
footage we're gonna make a video of uh
our you know Stevo and Bam craziest
moments together like all time that's
going to be epic and speaking of posting
footage you posted footage of you in
this uh campaign situation right before
you went to the hospital yeah and then I
think you deleted it yeah somebody made
me delete it just because they thought
that it was happening at that moment
when it was like eight days before so I
I didn't know that right right somebody
was filming it I was like you know what
this should just be documented in case
there's going to be some kind of
documentary in the future because I
always get my phone stolen or whatever
and then I completely lose all the
footage and uh you know like we said
they wouldn't let the gene about [ __ ] on
TV but how come they could let my
x-rayed little mini hard dick in
February my two inch hose be shown
without an issue right yeah when I broke
my tailbone I got an x-ray at the
hospital you could see my dick plain as
day in the coldness of February and they
had no problem putting that out there as
long as it's an x-ray do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude